yeah between
attention from men
that says
you're [ __ ] sexy
opposed to
i want to make you my wife 100 yes
that's different no no but i'm saying do
you think
you know they look for guys that are
smooth that i have game and guys know
that sex is a lot except a lot more
accessible now than it was in the past
so they they like i know of guys
i i know some guy friends that i
probably shouldn't say that i know that
i associate with but like they say that
they'll go to bars and they'll say
they're a lawyer they're a doctor and
get in bed and then they're actually
just working at walmart you know so
i think yeah i don't think they
differentiate it well i think women have
a very hard time differentiating
attention from men yeah i i think
one of the reasons why you may think
you're an 8.5 is because you get a lot
of attention from men right but but the
attention that you're getting from men
is because they want to [ __ ] you i'm
just going to be realistic with you
right you are hanging wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
let me tell you let me tell you
men are aesthetic creatures yeah let me
just try and give you some game about
men men are aesthetic creatures right we
will see a nice ass pretty face some
round tits right and we would say oh my
god that is attractive right and women
will
feel that attention to be like oh my god
he thinks i'm attractive but he thinks
you're attracted because he wants to
[ __ ] you not because he wants to make
you his wife yeah it's not because he
wants to make you
make making the mother of his children
it's not because he wants to put you
inside his home and keep you there for
the rest of his life it's because he
wants to get into your coochie yeah let
me let me say you need to learn to
differentiate between the two you asked
me about my physical rating i said eight
point five and you see that i didn't say
about my wife and you and you said it's
gonna go up when you get money but it
doesn't it doesn't matter if you have
money because you can't buy youth
then and
once you and once you hit 30 you're down
a point well you see yeah
kylie jenner looks scary
when you see her in person like that's
not attractive i'll tell you why money
like women they get the botox they get
the fillers but like men can see it like
they see your face moving weird
100
and it signals to them that like you're
you're a for fun instead of a wife okay
and so you could get the money you could
get the surgeries but you can't buy
youth you can't buy purity so so are you
really in the top let me explain to you
because that's an assumption that i'm
going to use the money to to do surgery
and do things the reason why if i'm
richard you know why i'll be hotter
because
to the world no men and women i'll tell
you why let me explain to you why and
i'll tell you this one the major
problems that you have listen do you
know what money buys money buys you time
that means that if i'm rich ninety
percent of your eggs are gone listen
that's okay but i'm talking about why i
talk about being hot right
if i got money i'm buying myself time in
the sense that i don't have to do half
of the things that i would have had to
do before i'll have a nutritionist if i
want to
okay
let me finish well let me finish because
it makes sense there's a calculation to
this if i got money i can buy i can get
a nutritionist or chef which means my
diet is going to be better
which means that my skin will look
better because i'm eating better quality
food and means that i'm eating the right
food i can go to the gym more it means
my body will
look bad how did you become this deluded
i want to say i want to say something
it's not being deluded you know what a
lot of the celebrities that are out
there that look amazing and everybody
thinks they're beautiful and they're so
hot and every man wants our girl just
even if it's just [ __ ] because we're
talking about looks because i said about
being hot okay wait let me rephrase what
they have been what i said is being rich
hot because if you see a lot of these
celebrities when they're average people
they were just average when they're rich
they're high wait wait wait wait wait
wait let me rephrase let me rephrase my
dear let me rephrase one doesn't give a
damn about your money so when you say
it's hang on so when you say if you get
rich you become hotter no she doesn't
mean her wealth she's number one
all right fine but you said when you
become rich you'll become hotter right
no the rich i become money come by me
she's she's saying she would get a
nutritionist
but the thing is you are still going to
be 30. yeah yeah do you understand
you're still going to be 30. so let me
i'm not trying to pick women against
each other right yeah but we have
linda over here who's 20 and a virgin
yes and we have you right you've you've
been you've been an abusive relationship
you're 29 you've gone through all this
stuff and you're
if you if you say you're 8.5 let's just
say you and linda are 8.5 right you're
both at 8.5 who do you think men are
going to choose it depends no it doesn't
depend i'm gonna go for the younger one
okay i want to say i want to say
wait you see i want to phrase what he
said he said about all men giving
attention no no the beta simps that
those simps will give the average woman
or any woman attention by the fault
because they look at women as sexual
objects so you're literally going to
think all that attention you're thinking
oh you know i'm paying but really it's
because the sims just look at anyone any
just the gender if you're a female
they'll just start giving you attention
and this is another problem number one
it's naive to think that i rely on my
looks to get in any anything in any
situation with men no way well my looks
and no okay okay listen
what things are where they look can you
get married
would you have gotten on the casillo
dating show if you weren't pretty oh
maybe not yeah and i'll tell you
something let me tell you something my
looks are my secondary gift
my first gift will be my personality and
the only reason why we're speaking is
yes it would be naive to think that i
rely on my looks number one number two
it would be naive to think that i'm
sitting here trying to display to to you
guys why i would want to be a wife to
you i don't want to be a wife if i
wanted to be your wife i wouldn't be
speaking to you differently because i
want you to be my man i don't have to to
be treated treating every single man
like he's my husband because he's a man
my husband
i'm gonna cut you off okay now sarah go
ahead what what no because she could
like you need to give other people so
what
trying to say is
you don't understand how you first of
all self-reflection and introspection is
a thing right
and i'm all about self-reflection and
introspection
and for this whole conversation that
we've been having today
i don't think you've understood the way
you've come across i really don't and i
think it's i'm not a psychologist i'm
not a psychiatrist so you can you can
throw away what i'm saying you can say
whatever that guy's talking [ __ ] right
but
the way in the things that are coming
out of your mouth are so contradictory
to the way you are acting
it it is very it is it is something to
be your wife
it's a sight to behold
i'm not gonna lie like i i've done this
show for i've been on your shelf what
six months now from that beginning right
and i've no i'm not gonna lie i've i've
rarely met women that have been that
contradictory it's not contradictory
it's just simply that you don't see
you're not understanding that there's
levels to this for example you compared
me and linda right yeah so okay no no
i'm not trying to pick you again
i was giving an example i'm gonna give
you another example and this is why i
say it depends
she is younger than me 10 years
basically i'm 29. yeah she's a virgin
i'm not definitely right okay as a man
who would you think listen listen and
this is the problem why is age and why
is virginity something that makes you a
better wife and i'll tell you why
no no no no okay okay can you ask a
question can i answer it really quickly
so so the reason is because the more
sexual partners you have the less chance
you have of being as many of you know i
was just banned on tick-tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform
if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible